the biggest mistakes of in the ukraine
war was that it was a intelligence
failure
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people i am so excited for the guest we
have for you today he's a retired
colonel from the finnish military
intelligence now lecturer colonel marty
carey welcome to trigonometry okay thank
you nice to be here
it is great to have you i'll call you
mara because that's uh the short version
of your name but listen before we get
started i just wanted to say for anyone
who doesn't know who you are we'll ask
you to tell everybody your background i
listened to a lecture that you gave
about russian culture history and
attitudes that's on youtube and it was
the best thing as a russian whose father
used to work in the russian government
everything you said was entirely true it
was just i've never seen anything this
good and the moment i watched i said to
francis we've got to get this guy on
because he's so good uh so just for
people watching this who don't know who
you are i can't wait to have this
conversation but before we do tell
everybody your background who are you
what has been your journey through life
how come you know so much about russia
russian culture russian history et
cetera ah okay okay so i was born quite
a long time ago
and when became became time to be
because we in finland we have uh
obligatory conscript service i went to
the airborne rangers i served as a
airborne ranger as a conscript and i i
was my plan was to become a
history teacher
but when i went the conscript service
and and uh i was teach how to jump with
the parachute in the night at the night
how to you know break break the
railroads and and blow up the bridges i
like this is quite nice and then i
applied to the cadet academy and and i
went to the cadet academy and i forget
the history
and then uh when i graduated from
carrick academy because i'm quite small
they put me to the armored briquette
because in that time we have soviet
tanks t55 bmv one so i worked with
mainly with bmp1
and then in 1988 i was recruited to
military intelligence because of my
knowledge of my languages
language skills and then i i from 1988
until 2017 i served in our military
intelligence
from
lieutenant to colonel
and during that trip i mainly worked in
finland but i was one year in bosnia as
a finnish continent commander because i
was in that age in the beginning of 2000
that i had to have the commanding post
to be promoted leader and colonel
colonel so i was one year in bosnia as a
company continuing commander i started
three years as a defense at tasha in
poland and ukraine
and
that's it so so and i i retired in the
end of 2017 as
a colonel
and i started
uh in the beginning of 2018 as a
university teacher in uvascular
quite difficult to pronounce you
vascular university
and i teach here now
intelligent analysis and also hybrid
threats
so that's that's
in a nutshell what i have done
and
it always seems to me that the best way
to start an interview is to go very
broad and it seems
to me that one of the great arrogances
about the west is that we think
everybody thinks like us
and we think that the whole world has
shares the same mentality but it's
proven time and time again particularly
in this case the russian the russians
and russia doesn't think like us so
let's just look at the big differences
between the rest between the west and
the russian mentality
ah that's a huge question no let's say
let's
let's approach that question in in that
way that okay when i was literally i was
sending to leningrad
leningrad to study russian language i
was there
and i i i make friends with russians and
i was thinking why they are
why they see the world
from the very different angle than i do
and i was wondering why why why why
and and it was bothering me and it was
bothering me and i understood that okay
there is something
why they are thinking different way and
not until i start my psd
in 2017
and i found a theory of strategic
culture it's a american
theory of international politics
and it was like you know i in that
moment when i found that theory of
strategic also i realized that okay
that's the theory by which i can explain
why the russians are doing the diffic
the things in a different way than we
are
so
so what
but the question what are the biggest
uh differences that's that's quite
challenging but okay let's say
let's say that okay for example the the
the
your attitude to the power
so so
we are living in democracy we are
electing our leaders every fourth year
in finland
and president every sixth year
and that's that's our system so we have
get used that okay we can we can change
our leaders and so on but the russians
they have they don't have had a system
that they can choose their leaders
because they had first they have chars
then they have the communist party and
now when
when they have put him they have had not
real possibilities to have elections and
choose the leaders so that i think the
first thing is
the the
relationship between the power
and the people
second
difference from
what i think is that
i speak at behalf of finns or or
europeans
we have a
finland is like a country of of
of
when you speak about legacy and and we
are
a country rule
rule of law
rule of law country it means that we
have laws
which protect us
from
from the authorities
that they can't behave as they want they
had to you know behave with us in a way
that they they they protect us
they they they behave
decently when they are working with us
and we know
what we can do what what is lawful what
is unlawful and what is the punishment
if we break the law
but uh
i think that russia is ruled by
law
it means that they have laws
but
the meaning of the laws is that
the leaders
can rule the people rule the system
by legislation so they have also laws
but but they can for example
if we think about the internet russian
segment of internet
they have a lot of laws which uh
limit
the the users uh possibilities you know
the final information and so on and so
on they say that okay this is for they
protect people from uh
pornography
or or from the
things which can
can
help you to make suicide for example
or they say that okay they protect
people against extremism
but what they do they can they can close
down for example opposite pages not only
pages horoscopy pages you know saying
okay this is extremist and it's it's
it's from the
point of view it's it's legal
because it's it's it's rule by law
country
do you understand what i'm doing
absolutely yeah absolutely yeah but
that's the other one the the the
approach
to due to the power
the the status of of of law
in the system
that's true and and i think also
the uh attitude against
attitude to violence for example
because they have they have long
long tradition of of state terror for
example even the great
even the great established operational
system
which means that that
the leader can use violence against
the people who are around
him and to normal people
very flexible
so there is no
there is no
legal limitations
to that how he can use his
his power for example
our president cannot send our
special service people to some other
country to poison a person
but in in russia it's possible
so i mean that
the approach to the use of violence
it's different than we have than they
have
so i think those those are the three
things which came to my mind
immediately
and in your lecture you talk a lot about
history and one of the things i loved
about it was very non-judgmental you
describe how russians think without
saying they are worse than us or better
than us or we are better and they are
worse or anything like that which i
thought was uh easier to hear for people
um and
i'm sorry because i like you know i i
like i i mastered in arts in russian
language and literature i like
i like the language it's the language of
tolstoy
dostoyevsky
so i i like the language i like the
people i don't have anything against
russian people i have russian friends
so when i speak russia i don't mean
russian people
normal ordinary russian people
i mean the leadership
yeah yes of course and and so talking
about the leadership one of the things
you point out is that is that because of
russian history whether it was the
mongol occupation being occupied by the
mongols for 150 years or some of the
tsars that came afterwards or the
communist regimes
after that
russia has always had a strong leader
and
one of the things i always tell people
in the west that they don't understand
is
stalin who killed 20 million or more of
his own people has a 70 approval rating
in russia today
why
because i think i think the russians
they have get used
to strong strong leader they have had
periods in the history they get it's
it's called smoothness
how do you say the english tons of
trouble
yeah times of troubles they in in end of
16th century for example they had times
of trouble when they didn't had a strong
leader
the poles attack and there was you know
internal
revolts and things like that people
a lot of people get killed
and there was no
[Music]
good
good coordination of leadership and so
on so in that time russians realized
that it's better to have a
strong leader than a chaos and you know
the the
the poles attacking and things like that
and and second time they realized that
when yeltsin became power and became
that that uh
democracy or how to say this is not the
democracy in that
point of view from our point of view
it's like
let's say criminal democracy or or
something like that so the russians
prefer strong leader because take the
strong leader can
have stability
they like stability we all like
stability we build in finland we build
our stability through the
democracy and and the russians are
building up their stability by a strong
leader
and do you think that has a lot to do
with geography when you see russia on
the map it's huge yeah
and so you really do not need somebody
who's that strong to hold
all those different places together all
those all that vast amounts of land
together because if you have someone who
perhaps is more liberal more democratic
than what you're going to get is
infighting people want breakaway group
breakaway republicans yeah
yeah
that the balkanization might happen if
you don't have a strong leader yeah you
were right that's right
and what you mentioned boris yeltsin uh
that was really the only time when
russia flirted with a pro-democratic
move it hadn't really happened in
history and what a lot of people in the
west don't realize is russians attitudes
to democracy and what russians think of
when they think about democracy can you
talk a little bit about what the 90s
meant for for russian and mentality and
why vladimir putin ended up being who he
is
i think it it started well
it started well became you know the i
think it started during the during
carpaccio perestroika
and and last night and things like that
people were i i was 1986 in in in
leningrad and it was time when the
perestroika started and glasnost started
people were quite you know enthusiastic
that okay now something
better will come they believe that okay
now the life will be better
and then became 1990s
and
it should have been democracy but it was
some kind of gangster
capitalism
so so the
the becoming oligarchs
took the coupons from the people and and
and and
and people lost everything what they had
inflation was in one year i think 94 the
inflation was 2 500
for example so so you you you just can't
live there and and
and
and that was the time when the people
get the impression that this is
democracy
this is democracy and then then in in
the new year 1999 2000 became a strong
leader
he was not in that time he was not yet a
strong leader but became a different
leader and the 1990s was behind and
people start to believe that okay this
might be a new start again at oil price
went like
that it means that the new president had
uh
long
a a lot of of of
economic power you know people somehow
connected the economical growth
with the president who
in fact hadn't nothing to do with the
oil price but anyhow it it happened in
that way that that oil price went up and
and some somebody people thought that
okay this is because putin is now
president our life is getting better and
better and better
but
he has been in some ways quite a good
president most western countries are in
horrendous amounts of debt as far as i
know russia is in no debt or very little
debt at the moment yeah you are right
that might change because yeah
yes you are right you because they they
sell oil they say sell costs they get a
lot of incomes from oil and gas so it
has helped him a lot
they have been quite wise because they
haven't spent all the money
they have put a lot of money in the
reserve reserves
and they have a lot of money and
reserves and they don't have depth as
you said so the economy
economical polity poli policy has been
quite wise
because one of the things we tend to
misinterpret about russia is corruption
we say that the the society is corrupt
the government is corrupt and of course
it is but it's corrupt in a very
different way than the corruption that
you will see in the united kingdom and
the united states could you explain that
to us please well it goes
if you read mark caleoti's book
about mafia it explains a lot how it
works it works in that way that if you
achieve some position in administration
you have right to saw
they say so
yeah
one part one part of the of the of the
state money
to yourself so you can you can steal
one part of the of the government money
to yourself and and if you are in a low
level in administration or system you
can still small portion
when you get up you you can steal more
and more and more and when you get high
you can steal tens or millions of
dollars in a year so
and it's it's it's everybody knows the
rules
so the rule goes in that way that don't
steal too much
don't
don't
don't steal from the wrong guy don't
don't steal from the wrong guy because
then you end troubles so it
everybody knows here's the rules
let's play according to these rules
don't break the rules
and of course we in the west are
hypocritical particularly in london
because the moment all of this corrupt
money flooded into the city of london
under blair's government we went right
ahead all the doors are open
yeah you were lucky they passed
basically
they passed helsinki we have just few of
them so here
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike already know
foreign language is perfectly boy gary
who a
biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is the
bibliotheque is the library you idiot
exactly you can never be too far away
from knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real-world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people so
you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones
babble is available as an app or online
and your progress will be synced across
all devices babel is offering our
listeners six months free with the
purchase of a six month subscription
with our promo code which is trigger go
to babble.com forward slash play and use
promo code trigger for an extra six
months for free we're even gonna get
francis on it you might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now yo
absolutely perfecto know what i mean
gary
colonel one of the things that
particularly you talked about in your
lecture as well is why russia
at a sort of instinctive level is very
fearful
of
invasion
uh ex western expansion uh it's fearful
of it perceives itself as being
surrounded and under threat can you talk
a little bit about that because i think
as we move the conversation into the
current situation that will help us
understand some of the thinking behind
the
the actions
oh you mentioned about the huge
it's a huge country it means that they
have a lot of borders
and and a lot of a lot of different uh
invaders has attacked russia from
mongols came
they were there 200 years then came
swedes swedes and finns because we have
always been been with swedes wherever
they go we go up with them because we
were part of sweden
700 years
they used to use fins you know for the
military purposes we have a saying that
the brave
brave swedish king fight until the last
fin
it's a finnish talk okay but anyhow
we attacked we attacked and then uh
napoleon
polls many times polls so so the the the
the russians have uh
in the
history in the family narratives there
is stories about
attacks
the germans attack in two world wars
they attack and now nato is according
the stories they are planning to attack
russia so that that's the huge huge uh
country and if you think about the area
from
the west west
borders of poland and ukraine
and you look to the moscow there's
nothing on it's a plane it's a plane
there's no you know rivers or there's a
little bit rivers but there's no
real obstacles like mountains or
seas or whatever so it's easy to attack
by horses by tanks and what whatever you
use when you attack
so it has created a feel of
being attacked
like uh they called or somebody called
it
roma you know it means that when the
nazis attacked 1941
to the russia it was called operation
paparossa so they called that russians
have a bar parrot in roma it means that
somebody will make a surprise attack
again to russia
and you also explained that it benefits
the leader of the country to create this
perception of threat because then he can
unite the people
and yeah say only a strong leader like
me
can can can
protect you
yes yes i
let's say that way that the 30 percent
east
is
family stories narratives 70 percent is
leadership is telling okay okay the the
nato is planning to attack us again or
the west is planning to attack us again
so it's it's like
how do you say in english you are
collecting under the flag or around the
flagpole or how does anything is locked
to the banner
yeah so it's it's
all the leaders
all around are using that also in russia
isn't it also a problem as well that
essentially putin is surrounded by yes
men
you're not gonna have somebody who
disagrees with putin or stands up to him
because if you do that you
or am i being facetious
you know
at all times they have a system called
bayern
boyars
who were noble
people who were surrounding the chart
and there was you know the
administrative boyers there was uh
military boyers and they were saving
serving the char
and char was giving them you know the
land and money and for for the good
service
but if he
he suspected that you are not behaving
well or if he is suspected that you are
planning a coup for example or the
reward or whatever
you might lose your head in as i told
you about even the the the terrible he
created the system like operation
and and it's it's like kgb and kgb of
16th century
and he used that that that kgb very very
flexible so and that time they lose
their head
and in style in time yes also us there
was neck shots and things like that
nowadays nowadays uh you will be
transferred to the you will be head of
the railway administration or the
governor of kaliningrad but they don't
they don't shoot any more people but
anyhow
if the chart is not satisfied for your
services as a boyar you will be
transferred to the lower post even for
example is taking care of the
of the
i don't remember he is now in position
where he take care of environment
and he used to be in a very high
position
but isn't that a problem because what
that creates is a uniformity of thought
and it also means that bad ideas don't
get challenged particularly putin's bad
ideas so currently they're at war i mean
will any generals go to putin and go
look i think we've made a mistake here
because we've got massive amounts of
casualties and in this part of the
country the ukrainians are winning
yeah i think because i i teach
intelligence in university
and the
task of intelligence is provide
objective information to decision making
so
intelligence is providing
objective information decision makers
and then we have decision makers who
make decisions
based on the information given by
intelligence and given by other other
people like operative people and and so
on
but in russia the problem is that it's
it's mixed
it mixed because around putin there is
narishkin
and born nico who are intel guys
so they are
in the inner circle they are those guys
who are
also making the decisions
so so the idea of use of intelligence
doesn't work there because
the intelligence doesn't provide
objective information to the decision
makers because part of the decision
makers
are intel people
do you understand what i'm trying to
explain yeah so there's no there's no
division
there's there should be a division intel
guys
provide intel
decision makers
make decisions but they're intel guys
are decision makers
so it it it it it twists
that this is a making process as you say
that it's it might cause that there yes
man and and and when the
subordinators
who are providing the information making
the reports or making the collection
they know what the boss wants to hear i
mean not the highest boss but they both
work off or on risking they make the
reports
according
the expected vcs of of of the boss of
the s that
that particular service and it was also
the system so
so it's it's
i think the one or the
the biggest mistakes of in the ukraine
war was that it was uh intelligence
failure
it was intelligence failure i i have
analyzed that and i think it was a
intelligence failure
well let's explore that mara what do you
mean by that
i i mean that okay
uh if you think about the intelligence
cycle we have collection we have
analyzes we have delivery or reporting
and then idea is that you collect data
you analyze data and make the the
data
to intelligence you provide that
intelligence and reports
to your your customer and it should
cause wisdom
it should cause knowledge and in best
case it should
cause wisdom in the head of the decision
maker
from data to wisdom it's it's quite
challenging job
but it works if you are
objective
honest and so on but
if you have three services as they have
you know
foreign service foreign intel
uh
fsb and military intelligence you have
three services who are competing
who are competing for the resources
and
and
the
money for example so they they they they
think that okay my boss want to hear
this kind of reporting so they provide
probably a wrong reporting because they
think that okay
if i tell bad news he don't like me i
will not get get resources
and that's why it might as a stalin of
course he didn't believe the intel which
was
was provided by rickard sergey ricardo
soroge was
the best
best uh
operative
uh operative
officer in in tokyo he said that okay
the germans will attack in the mid of
june 1941 stalin believe that
because he has his own ideas
he has his own indicators which he was
following
and other people with telling you know
that no the german will not attack
because they know that the stalin want
to hear that okay the germans will not
attack this is the same system in in now
i think putin
didn't
believe
those who told that okay we should not
attack ukraine he believed those guys
who said okay we can attack ukraine
because it goes easy as it went in 2014
in crimea for example i haven't been
there but i have analyzed that that that
might be
one reason why why this all happened
well colonel this is the question that i
think a lot of people suddenly wanted to
know the answer to
why did vladimir putin invade ukraine
some people say
as we talked about earlier that it's the
threat of nato expansion he cannot allow
nato in ukraine other people say well
he's been talking we had a former
advisor to vladimir putin on our show
called andrei leonov who talked about
how since since the moment he came to
power putin was talking about we want to
go back to 1997 when no eastern european
countries were nato basically he he
longs to recreate the soviet union
what's the truth why did he invade
i think those both are right but one i
think one reason is that they are fear
about the color revolutions because the
system you go as i i told you you you if
you get the position in in the system
you get the high positioning system
you get you you have a access to the
money
you have access to money and you you can
you can you can saw
money
uh as
much as
your uh people in your level
you know administrative
admin can cancel
if you are high you can steal a lot of
money
if you are lower you can steal
not so much money as the guys who are up
there but anyhow you can still
so and if you have a system that okay we
vote our leaders every fourth year
it might happen that you will be not in
a position anymore where you can still
so the color revolutions is a threat for
the system
where uh
where is the in-built corruptions
corruption like in russian
administration and
and that's why
they are afraid of the color revolutions
i think that's one reason and what
happened in in in ukraine in maidan
2014 it was a color revolution
and they were afraid that it will spread
also to russia it happened it almost
happened in in belarus the russians went
in it almost happened in in in
kazakhstan the russians went in and so
so they are trying to put down
all the possible
color revolutions
which are
you know might rise in the neighborhood
in in granted in ukraine they didn't
manage
and that is one reason why they attack
of course there's a you know that all
the slay
slavs are uh one people and nato
expansion we had to put the buffers on
which we have lost when the soviet union
break down and things like that but i
think one reason is that that that that
system that you had to protect that
kleptocratic system
and and not let the color revolutions
come in to russia
so the people at the top they fear a
change of system because it means they
will no longer have the power and the
opportunity to profit from having the
power
yeah
that's one reason yes
that makes sense uh but why now they
tried and fought in 2014 they they took
crimea they started a small local civil
war in the east of ukraine why did they
attack now in 2022 what was the reason
to do it now
i think i think one reason was that they
tried to solve the question of donbass
and and they tried to solve the the don
pass question
and the the
because there was a change of president
united states they thought that okay he
might be not so strong we can now
you know try something another thing was
that they saw that zelensky was
was fighting against the
pro-soviet pro pro-orisa
actors
in in ukraine for example he was made by
chuck television channels were closed
year ago in february january february so
so zelensky was i'm sorry to interrupt
just for people who don't know
medvedchuk is the leader of a
pro-russian party uh whose i think
daughter's godfather is vladimir putin
so this is yes this is very much
pro-russian guy in ukraine who was
actively working against president
zielenski and zielinski shut down his tv
channel so medvedchuk was you know
making a huge
information
warfare information campaigns
pro russia in ukraine and zelensky
closed
close that possibility and chains of
president united states
and also
you know they i think the the don pass
to take care of don pass it's cost a lot
so i think they thought also though that
they had somehow solved the problem with
don pass i mean the rebel rebel areas
and and if you put all this together
you
come to the conclusion that okay
it's time to attack because
i think when when they concentrate the
forces
in in in the beginning in the end of
last year i thought that the idea is to
put the pressure
to kiev to put the pressure on zelensky
that he would accept
open the negotiations
on minsk to agreement
but when a macron went to moscow and
stalls went to moscow they came
from there to kiev
and back they
home and sell there was no discussions
about the opening uh the minsk two
agreement then i realized okay this is
this is not the exercise they will
attack but i think they will i thought
they will not attack so deep with the so
deep uh
targets as they did
because they had only 190 000
troops
and the ukrainians had
mob they can mobilize 200 000 troops so
i think that's
that's miscalculation because you had to
have uh
three times
so much forces as a defender so i think
that they they make you know uh
just they take my two karkov
and that they do kahoka reservoir
because they needed water to do crimea
for example so but this surprised me
that they are they are attacking
from four different
directions
no no center of gravity of the attack
and
no i don't know we come back to your
point about poor intelligence and not
being not being given the right
information francis let me just finish
up on this point sure could this have
been prevented colonel
ah you me the russian attack
yes
no
no yes yes if
if
they would had open negotiations about
uh minsk two
that might have been a solution
that might have prevent the war
what if ukraine said we're never joining
nato
that might also that might also have
been you know the
solution yes yes you are right
um we've been talking and
corruption about corruption
now this obviously wasn't a primary
motivator but it might have been a
secondary motivator we're talking about
people
whose motivations for progressing up the
ladder are as you said soaring off a bit
for themselves the higher up the louder
you go the more you can soar off
now they might invite er advise vladimir
putin to invade because if they think
hang on the war isn't going to last for
very long we'll take over all of this
part of ukraine we'll have all of these
resources
that means inevitably some of that will
go to me some of these natural resources
will go to me could that have been a
motivator as well people acting in their
own self-interest
that might be also but i think that that
that has not been the main
main
driver
okay and people talk a lot about the
fact that ukraine is quite is it quite
rich in gas and that could have been uh
a factor as well because then that
undermines a russian position because
russia provides much of europe in
particular germany with gas
no i think the the russian has gas
enough
the russians have
have oil enough i think the the ukraine
has oil provider or gas provider
is not so vital to russia what what
ukraine provides is is
weed for example
and and and and
things like that but i think
the economical reason is not the main
it's not even the second
second uh
important uh reason to attack i think
yeah
and uh colonel what does all of this
mean for the standoff which we now have
between nato and russia because
people who understand the geography of
eastern europe as you do know that
kaliningrad for example is a piece of
russia that is disconnected from the
main uh body of russia by uh latvia and
lithuania
and these are countries that are now
part of nato
given that
you know part of the of the national
mentality is about making sure you're
safe and part of it is about expanding
borders bringing the russian people
under one umbrella controlling the
buffer zone of eastern europe do you
think uh as andre larrion have told us
for example that putin wants to keep
going now obviously
the troops haven't done as well as he
hoped and it's been a big failure i
think that's only how people see it in
the kremlin at the moment
do you think he has ambition to go
further
you mean to open the door to open the
corridor to kaliningrad
and more and more to go further than
ukraine no i think now they don't have a
power
because they have they have lost a lot
of a lot of men lots of
techniques uh in in ukraine so they had
to know
to take the bread
before they can do anything else
will they do i think that
i think that ukraine has taught them a
lesson
so they think twice
if they go somewhere else yes but what
i'm asking you is is imagine ukraine had
gone very well for russia they come in
they take half the country no problem
ukrainian surrender like they did in
2014
would they then keep going or is it just
about ukraine no i think it might have
would have been like that you described
they would keep going
yeah they might would they might have to
keep being
going yes
yeah
why why would they keep going explain to
our viewers why because they have idea
that okay
to protect mother russia you had to have
buffer zones you you had to have so in
old time they had also packed all the
eastern bloc countries and then you had
the second second line of defense was
baltic states belarus
ukraine and so on so you had
two buffer
two zones of defense before the madras
mother russia was you know under the
attack so probably they would had
somehow expand
the
the buffer zone
further on
hey constantine do you like shopping no
in russia you skin bear with your bare
hands and wear it obviously this is for
men only women and small children are
allowed to use knife where did you get
your blazer from it's made out of bear
bubbuska created it for me using nothing
but her own bare hands no pun intended i
wondered what the smell was but for
those of you who do want an easy
no-hassle solution to the grind of going
shopping then stitch fix is for you
stitch fix is a service for both men and
women and makes shopping for clothes
easy to get started go to stitch fix dot
co dot uk forward slash trigger to set
up your profile they'll deliver clothes
chosen just for you in your taste size
and budget and by taste they mean
something that will look good instead of
showing the world you're having a
mid-life crisis like me the items you
buy arrive at your door a few days later
you try everything on at home decide
what to keep and then send anything else
back it's so easy you just pay 10 pounds
each time you order which is credited
towards the items you keep and you'll
get twenty percent off when you keep all
five items there's no subscription plus
shipping returns and exchanges are easy
and free stitch fix does the hard work
for you making shopping for clubs easy
and hassle free get started today at
stitchfix dot co dot uk forward slash
trigger and get 20 off when you keep all
five items can you order fresh siberian
bear skin from stitch fix
possibly go to stitch fix dot co dot uk
forward slash trigger to find out
why is it that
the majority of russians are
pro-putin they're very supportive of
putin
and in particular during the war surely
they should have would they not have
seen you know their own country as an
aggressor
but you know they they are in
information about comb
they are in information they in 2019
they had law we said that they russell
had to have capabilities to to isolate
the russian segment of internet from the
global internet
and and now they have capabilities
to isolate
the russian segment
uh they haven't done that yet they have
not isolated that day segment yet but
they have capabilities but what they
have done
they have isolated
the mentality or the information
of russian people from the from the
information of the west
so so they have closed all the
non-official channels dust
television channel dust closed down and
and
nova gazetta was closed
a homa's queer radio kennel channel was
closed because they have a law they just
less than a month ago they they
accepted the law that if you speak
not
the the official truth you might get
uh even 15 years jail so the people are
now very
very afraid
to speak
something else that what is obviously
accepted for example
words like war and and
and that like that kind of
words they are forbidden
so you can't say this is a war you have
to say it's a special military operation
and if you get that information 25
hours
in a day
from television
so you start to believe that
like a chinese water torture
you get drop
on your heads one drop doesn't do
anything but if you get drop
100 or thousands of drops in a head your
head starts
you get a headache
so it's the same
because if you every evening you open
the tv and you hear that okay in in kiev
the leaders in kiev they are nazis
and and so on and so on you start to
believe that
and and you
you hear that okay the russian forces
are participating in a special operation
because they are trying to get
rid of the nazis you start to believe
that
and and you have not the alternative
truth
which which you might get from the west
so so it means that
and and if and of course
you believe that and of course if you
are stopped in the street
at the interview are you supporting
putin or not
guess what the people usually answer
so it i think it's close like that
and
the problem is is is what once that
happens and you've got the majority
behind him it makes a leader very strong
doesn't it because if there's no if you
know if there's no criticism and there's
no public backlash then there's going to
be less reason for him to
think about his actions and maybe change
them
yeah but in the russian days you know
always has been in soviet union and
russia has been one thing which i
learned in 1986 in leningrad that they
has
a lot of levels of the truth
the truth in the newspapers is different
than the truth on the street and the the
truth on the street is different than
the truth in the kitchen in the kitchen
table
so so we don't know
we don't we don't make the balls
or they don't make the balls in a
kitchen
they make the balls in the streets on
the streets so
we don't exactly know what is the real
support of of the present
yes and you mentioned uh different
levels of truth one of the most
fascinating parts of your lecture for me
was when you talked about language and
how in russian there are different words
for truth and i've never thought about
this but it is accurate the way you
describe it we have uh different words
for truth and some of them mean
that it's absolutely true but some of
them are more flexible and so people are
more flexible and you also talked about
the fact that in russia there is this
feeling among people and this is
definitely true that if i lie for the
benefit of my country or for the benefit
of my group
uh then other people will be okay and
they will also agree that i am telling
the truth in inverted commerce even
though they know i'm lying because they
know it's for our collective benefit can
you explain a little bit about that
yeah they call it it's it's like
it's in russia it's called
it's like a
[Music]
company guarantee or how do you
translate it collective responsibility
it's
yeah okay it means that okay when the
russians went to crimea the russian
forces went to crimea no insignia
no no any any insignias that they are
russian soldiers they went to crimea
and they start to you know take the the
objects
and and and
to their hand i mean the airport and
and and and guardians and so on
and people people were wondering who
they are and put they say they are not
russian soldiers
and we in west we were thinking okay if
they are not russian soldiers who they
are
and after three days russian uh putin
said okay they are russian soldiers so
so putin gained three
uh three days advantage
by telling the tactical truth
so he was denying that they are they are
russian soldiers he said that they are
not
and i i was thinking okay if if our
president would say that okay those
people are not my soldiers the soldiers
would be very angry
but
because the russian soldiers understood
that it was
uh
he was you know denying us because he's
uh achieving time he is he's bluffing
the the west intel and so on they
accepted that they were not saying that
hey we are russell's soldiers don't
don't
don't forget that we are here
so so that's one example
so so you can use the tactical truth to
bluff
yeah to get people confused as as lavrov
when they started negotiation in
istanbul
he said that we have not attacked
ukraine yes
because
the basic assumption of the negotiations
was that
russia was
russo has attacked ukraine that was the
basic assumption everybody has you know
the notes according that basic
assumption that okay we negotiate
we will
implement this negotiation according the
basic assumption that okay russia has
attacked ukraine and everybody was ready
to start from that point of view and he
came there and said we have not attacked
ukraine everybody was
looking their papers how how how can i
start now because he said that
they have not attacked us
and what you're saying as well to us as
well is people in russia don't mind that
their president didn't tell the truth
about crimea about russian soldiers or
they don't mind that they didn't tell
the truth about what's happening in
ukraine they they can
they can be okay with that because it's
for the benefit of the country yeah
that's that system of the parocha so it
means that okay he was clever
yes he was clever because between truth
and the lie
there is a lot of
let's say 50 says but i don't think that
movie now 50 states of gray
where you can flexible move very
flexible you can move in that and what
does that mean for
what we hear in the west
in russian media like rt or sputnik or
whatever
are those reliable uh tv channels for
people to to get the information from
no i think in many countries they have
closed
rt for example because they consider
that it's not reliable source of
information
but
of course
we
we can follow because it's it's quite
important to also follow with arti for
example telling because
if you are able to interpret
what if if they are saying something and
you can understand
why they are saying something what is
behind that that uh tactical truth
so so so i think it's not wise to close
it's it's it's much more wise to monitor
and think
from the point of view of for example
tactical truth why they no i agree with
you about closing i but what i'm getting
at is i think some people have been
rather than watching and interpreting
they've been watching and believing
yeah
yeah what did what we did in finland
already
let's say more than 10 years ago we
opened we have
because i thought that we have two
officer languages we have swedish and
finnish
two of uh two
officer languages but we have also news
in russia
and in sami sami is a language which
they speak the lab people in up up in
lapland they speak sami language so we
have when you open tv you you you at
five o'clock you get news
in in finnish
in swedish in sami and in russia
so even sami and russell are not our
official languages so so we decided that
we will fight the information warfare
by telling
the finished route
which is much more i think it's much
more close
to the real truth it's not tactical
truth but it's it's you know the the
based on mainly on the facts
so i think it's it's it's a good system
we had a good system for to inform make
the information wait information warfare
and
where does this leave putin now because
i think most people would acknowledge
for russia this has not been a success
they've lost a lot of men their
reputation has been damaged his
reputation has been damaged
it's gonna probably end in some kind of
stalemate
where does he go from here
i think
this yeah they have stalemate in kiev
area they have stalemate in north they
have still still made in in in in
non-operational direction i mean the
rebel areas what they are
okay they will the the the victory day
ninth of may
so they had to have something to
show to the people
we have one
and what they probably do they do
they because they said that okay
we the the main reason of the operation
was to protect
those two
rebel republics or rebel areas they call
them republics
so what they do that i think that they
are trying to get that old nobel russia
area it means that from from donbass to
to crimea
so the idea is that
the the the shores of azova sea from
from the rebels areas to crimea on the
nepal river up north
they it's called the area is called
noborossia
and i think think that they
are before the 9th of of may they are
trying to take
that area and the key of of of that area
is mario paul
so they i think they are pushing now
heart marijuana and if they get that
they can say okay
this is what we
were trying to get and now now we get
that we won the war
and and and that should have happened
before the 9th of may because then they
can you know
glorify all the sec the the losses which
they have had during the war
because they fight against the nazis
nazis again and and now we get that
novorossiya now people in in in those
two
republics uh are safe and free
and i know that your background is not
in decision making it's an intelligence
and an analysis
but if i were a decision maker and i
came to you and i said colonel
i want to make sure
that this is the end that whatever
happens in ukraine now uh peace is
upheld that russia does not advance
further that they're not even thinking
about this as a western decision maker
what would you say to me what would your
advice be
ah that's a
bad but
a difficult difficult question i think
first of all
don't escalate as nato don't escalate
second support ukraine
uh uh
every way
as you can
wait are those two contradictory to each
other
no no because you can economically
humanitarian you can support ukraine you
can you can provide ukraine
weapons
but
it doesn't it doesn't mean escalation
escalation means that there's not a
fighter and russian fighter and they are
fighting in the air but if you provide
weapons for example we sent a lot of a
lot of weapons finland said a lot of
weapons
to ukraine
as a a member of europe union as all the
airborne nations teach
so and and uk also send it javelins
which has been very good weapon it has
provided to be a very good weapon
against the tanks but anyhow so i would
say that okay don't escalate support
ukraine support the peace process
and beware
be ready if something bad happened
don't believe everything
that might be my advices
do you think he will use chemical
weapons
[Music]
i think not
i think because it would escalate it
would be the red line why would he use
those weapons
what what would he gain because now he
hasn't gained
a lot of success by attacking
normally by ground forces
what would he gain
by using the chemical weapon especially
if you looked for example the ukrainian
ukrainian
videos you see that all the ukrainian
soldiers they have the gas masks ready
beside them so it means that ukrainians
are saying that we are ready if you use
a
chemical weapon we are ready so don't
use that because there is no
there is no effect
that makes sense all right well colonel
it's been uh really great to to get your
thoughts on everything that's going on
uh we're going to ask you a couple of
questions from our supporters for our
supporters but before we do the question
we always finish with
is what's the one thing that we're not
talking about here in the west that you
think we should be
uh you know related with russia or
ukraine or anything at all
anything would i want to speak yeah yes
but for example about myself
no uh well if you think we don't talk
about you enough
then yes
okay so i think what is what is now very
interesting is is is the
what is going on is nato discussing
about nato membership in finland
finland and sweden
because
before the ukrainian war
according to polls in polls in finland
the supporters the number of supporters
of percent as percentage of supporters
supporters of nato was about
30
28 30
when the war broke out
now
62 percent of finns support the nato
membership
so it doubled the number doubled so so
62
now
support nato membership in finland and
28 is against
so it means that
because we have had a lot long time
discussions should we join or should we
not join but our politicians
they have not been brave enough
to start the process and now now it
seems that the people
have overrun
the politicians
the people has overrun the politicians
and now the politicians tried to
to fix the situation they tried to find
a position
in this changed situation
and almost all the politicians
surprisingly
uh for the nato membership now
because they realize that
that people want to join nato
yes
so there's a great irony here in in
attempting to if if the rationale of
putin's invasion is partly about pushing
nato back he's actually strengthened
nato with what he's done yes yes yeah
we were talking that we should send to
kremlin a lot of those military merit
medals
because they have they have worked hard
for finnish defense
[Laughter]
well on that i have you know colonel
it's been an absolute pleasure uh before
we ask you before we wrap up the
interview and ask you questions for our
supporters uh i know you're active on
twitter uh where else should people go
to to see your thoughts and your
commentary i'll link it in but i i link
it in i'm
i'm just following business things but
i'm twitter i'm i'm a twitter man
so twitter is my main main media
okay we'll make sure to put the link to
your brilliant lecture and your twitter
handle in the description of the video
with that thank you for coming on the
show and thank you all for watching and
listening i will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out at 7pm uk
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
from your perspective what could be done
to turn the russians to western europe
more as in become more westernized